got to somehow break the cycle on the
Kent Coast this morning a prime minister
determined to succeed where his
predecessors failed you can do it from
here yes as border Falls grapple with
thousands of Channel Crossings new
arrivals being processed not far away
a bold plan to stop the boats if you
come here illegally you can't claim
Asylum you can't benefit from our modern
slavery protections you can't make
spurious human rights claims and you
can't stay
we will detain those who come here
illegally and then remove them in weeks
where do you think your predecessors
went wrong why are you different and can
I also ask what does success look like
to you will you be setting targets for
where you want the numbers to be in a
year's time so this is not about
dwelling on the past because the
situation has just got far worse unless
we do something novel that we do
something bold to try and stop it and
that's what our legislation today does
now you know successes are stopping the
boats earlier in the day it was a Home
Secretary setting out a plan that may
well end up being defended in court I am
confident that this bill is compatible
with International obligations the
practicalities are enormous but the
message clear
for a government not to respond to waves
of illegal migrants breaching our
borders would be to betray the will of
the people we were elected to serve
their sense of fair play has been tested
Beyond its limits and they've seen the
country taken for a ride
Shadow Home Secretary but for labor it's
just more of the same
the Home Secretary has said anyone who
arrives illegally will be deemed
inadmissible and either returned to the
country they arrive from or a safe Third
Country
only that wasn't this Home Secretary it
was the last one
and that wasn't this bill it was the
last one passed only a year ago which
did not work
and there were moments of high emotion
that I will never vote for legislation
that would have led to my parents being
detained and dumped in Rwanda
the government wants immigration to
become a dividing line with labor at the
next election they know this is
traditional safe Tory ground that could
sway votes the trouble is it's not just
about talking tough on immigration it's
about delivering and there is no sense
at least in the short term that this
legislation alone can do that
his party are on side for now Rishi
sunak has gone further than his
predecessors but that doesn't mean he'll
stop the boats Ali Fortescue Sky News
Westminster